[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في ظل انسداد سياسي كامل في
ليبيا وتظهر امني متفاقم تحتضن العاصمه
التونسيه لقاء
اقليميا ثلاثيا يجمع تونس بالجزائر ومصر
في مسع لتاكيد حل سياسي لا يقصي اي طرف
ويرفض الاحتكام الى قوه السلاح تونس ومصر
والجزائر دول فاعله في المشهد الليبي فضلا
عن كونها دول جاره معنيه بشكل مباشر بتظهر
الوضع في هذا البلد ف ما هي الاسس التي
ترتكز عليها ما سميت مبادره تونسيه لحل
النزاع في ليبيا وما علاقه بالاتفاقات
السابقه وتحديدا اتفاق الخيرات نناقش
الموضوع بعد تقرير ناصر اي
الطاهر مصر تونس الجزائر معا يتحرك جيران
ليبيا المتضررون اقتصاديا وامنيا من
ازمتها المستفحل يؤمنون بان الحل يتعين ان
يكون ليبيا لكنهم يريدون الاسهام في وضع
اسس حل توافقي ينهي تنازع الشرعيات بين
الفرقاء الليبي
ولا غنى هنا عن جمعهم اولا حول طاوله حوار
واحده سيكون ذلك اذا تحقق حوارا وطنيا
ليبيا برعايه الامم المتحده وتزكيه الدول
الثلاث تعذر ذاك الحوار في القاهره
فمباشرة
من حديث البعض عما وصفوها
بمناورة كما يبدو الحرص على تفادي تشتيت
الجهود وتعدد المبادرات
والمسارات والان لا يعرف ايه حظوظ تملك
مبادره الرئيس التونسي الباجي قائد السبسي
التي انخرطت فيها مصر والجزائر مع انهما
لا تنظران الى الوضع في ليبيا بالضروره من
الزاويه نفسها ثمت اطراف ليبيه بدت لها
المبادره غامضه لكن المعروف من اهدافها
يتلخص في دفع الليبيين بمختلف توجه هم
وانتماءاتهم الفكريه والايديولوجيا الى
الحوار وتذليل الخلافات حول تنفيذ اتفاق
صخيرات
المغربيه ورفض اي توجه نحو حل عسكري وكذا
مواصله دعم دور الامم المتحده كمض اساسيه
لاي حل سياسي ومع ان المسعى ثلاثي فثم
تحليلات ترى الجزائر الداخله بقوه على خط
المساعي الاقليميه اكثر قبولا لدى اغلب
الاطراف الليبيه وذاتها الرساله تبعثها
الزياره القريبه للوزير الجزائري للشؤون
المغاربيه والاتحاد الافريقيه وجامعه
الدول العربيه عبد القادر مساهل الى عدد
من المناطق الليبيه لم تحصر في طرابلس او
تبرج لكن ذلك وحده لا يضمن سيناريو مغايرا
لما انتهت اليه مبادرات
سابقه فخص حفتر يعتقدون ان الرجل المدعوم
من بعض العرب والذي نسج علاقه مصلحه مع
موسكو سيرفض في النهايه اي مبادره للحل
فهو لن يقبل بالتنازل عن صلاحياته
العسكريه او تلك التي يطمح اليها كما انه
يحسب نفسه منتصرا عسكريا لا محاله لعله لم
يسمع تحذير الممثل الخاص للامين العام
للامم المتحده مارتن كوبلر من السعي
لتحقيق مكاسب سياسيه بالقوه ولا دعوته
الليبيين كافه الى تغليب مصلحه بلدهم على
كل الاعتبارات فهل يفعلون في غمره
الاحتفالات بذكرى ثوره وحدتهم جميعا قبل
سته
اعوام ينضم الينا من تونس بشير الجويني
باحث في العلاقات الدوليه ومختص في الشان
الليبي وينضم الينا من طرابلس صلاح الشلوي
محلل سياسي ليبي اهلا بكم ابدا معك ضيفي
من تونس بشير الجويني اذا كنا نتكلم عن
مبادره تونسيه على ما ترتكز هذه المبادره
المبادره شكرا على الدعوه اولا المبادره
كما قلت وكما ورده في تقريركم هي مبادره
كانت نابعه من وعي بانه الوضع الان في
ليبيا لا يمس فقط ليبيا لكن ايضا يمس
جيرانها وبالاخص دول الطوق اساسا مصر
الجزائر وتونس هذه الدول التي تضررت مما
يحصل في ليبيا ولا زالت تتضرر الحل في
ليبيا سيكون له انعكاسات ايجابيه على هذه
الدول سيكون له ايضا انعكاسات ايجابيه على
ما هي مرتكزاته بش طبعا المعالم ما هي
مرتكزاته ما الذي يختلف هذه المره عنما تم
في الخيرا
نعم المرتكزات الان فيها اقرار بانه الحل
لا يمكن ان يكون الا سياسيا لاحظنا في
يعني بيان وزاره الخارجيه المصريه كما
لاحظنا في تصريحات وزير الخارجيه التونسي
انه هناك حرص وتوصيه وايضا الجزائري انه
هناك حرص وتوصيه على نقاط ثلاث النقطه
الاولى هو انه وحده التراب الليبي يعني كل
الدعوات الى تقسيم تم تجاوزها بموجب هذه
المبادره والمبادرات السابقه ايضا والنقطه
الثانيه المهمه انه الحل لن يكون عسكريا
الحل سيكون سياسيا وعلى طاويله المفاوضات
النقطه الاخيره ممكن المهمه والتي تتم
النقطتين الاولتين هو نقطه انه لن يكون
لليبيا حكم عسكري سيكون الحكم سياسي سيتم
المواصله في اتفاق الخيرات ستفتح افاق
لتعديله بما يضمن لجميع الاطراف في شمال
البلاد جنوبها في شرقها وفي غربها ما يمكن
لهم من موقع ولا موضع في هذه التشكيله
المقبله دون ان يكون الطرف السياسي يعني
المسيطر هو العسكر كما تروج له بعض
الاطراف طبعا الملاحظه المهمه انا يعني
اود ان اقولها هو استباق يعني ولا تغيير
الموعد الذي كان من المفترض انه يكون في
مارس الى 19 و20 فبراير هذا مهم جدا وفيه
اشاره انه الفرصه الضائعه كما ورد في
التقرير فرصه لقاء حفتر بالسراج في ال مصر
كانت لها يعني انعكاسات هذه الانعكاسات
تجلت في القاهره عفوا هذه الانعكاسات تجلت
في انه تم التسريع في المسار السياسي الذي
تقوده تونس بمشاركه مصريه جزائريه طيب
دعني اسال ضيفي من ط صلاح الشلو فيما
يتعلق بهذه المبادره وامكانيه نجاحها
عندما يكون تتالف هذه المبادره من دول
جاره لليبيا كتونس والجزائر
و مصر ماذا عن توقيت المبادره الم تاتي
متاخره شيئا
ما مساء الخير عبد القادر م لضيفك ولكل
مشاهدي قناه
الجزيره في تصوري انه الحديث عن مبادره في
تونس ربما في شيء من ال من ال من التعميم
يعني ليس هناك شيء يمكن الحديث عليه بمعنى
مبادره كل اللي يمكن ان يطلق عليه في تونس
هو
تشاوتشو ما زالت الى الان لم تفرز ولم
يعني تفسح عم رغبه او ما يريده كل الاطراف
اقليميه مما يجري او موقفهم الحقيقي مما
يجري في ليبيا اليوم ليبيا معروفه في
تاريخها الجيوسياسي من القدم منذ بدايه
الملكيه ان هناك توازن قوه بين الجزائر في
الشرق في الغرب وبين مصر في الغرب وهذا ما
دعى الملك الراحل ادريس عليه رحمه الله ان
هو يقبل بفكره وجود قواعد عسكريه قاعده
انجليزيه في غرب في شرق البلاد في العدم
وقاعده امريكيه في غربها في الملاحه او في
قاعده ويلز هذا بسبب اختلال التوازن
الجيوسياسي في في المنطقه وهذا التوازن
مازال مستم هذا الاختلال في التوازن مازال
مستمر الى اليوم لذلك نرى الدورين
الجزائري والمصري على ال بشكل على الخصوص
يحاول كل منهما ان هو يعالج هذا الاختلال
رهانا على الوقت ا حاولت ال يعني
حاول حاولت مصر ان هي تبادر بجمع الاطراف
ولكن طبعا كانت تعاني
المبادره المصريه كانت تعاني بان لم تحز
على ثقه الاطراف لان بعض الاطراف تعتبرها
م يمكن تسميته بانه مبادره وانما هي عباره
عن مشاورات هناك حديث الان على افكار يتم
بلورتها هناك حديث عن تنازلات سيطلب من
جميع الاطراف تقديمها من اجل الوصول الى
تسويه سياسيه في ليبيا اذا ماذا نسمي هذه
المساله
هو طبعا
هذه هذا ما قدمته اطراف الحوار الليبي
نفسها لما اجتمعت في الحمامات قالت كل هذه
الافكار واجتمعت كل الاطراف وتكلمت على ما
سميته انت بالتنازلات وهي تعديلات وفق وفق
اتفاق الصخيرات هذه هي المرجعيه التي
عرضها اطراف الحوار الليبي واظن ان ما
يجري الان التشاور حول في تونس هو هي
الافكار التي انتجت في الحمامات وليست شيء
جديد يعني ليست هناك شيء جديد يمكن الحديث
عليه حتى التوقيت عندما يعني الان نحنا
كان المفترض هذا اللقاء او التشاو تكون في
مارس ولكن الجزائر الان مقبله على
انتخابات تشريعيه في مايو فليس من من
الممكن لها ان هي تشرف على عمليه معقده
وحل اشتباك وحل صراع في ليبيا في نفس
الوقت تخوض انتخابات باسلوب جديد اول مره
يحدث في تاريخ الجزائر في في في هذه
الفتره اظن
ان الجميع يشعر لكن الذي ينبغي ان نحن
ندركه تماما ان على الاطراف ان تفهم
القضيه الليبيه ليبيا ليست المشكله ليبيا
تعاني ايضا من مشكله الارهاب الذي تعانيه
ليبيا ليس الصنعه ليبيه فقط يعني عندنا 20
قائد ميداني اي من التنظيمات
المتطرفه انصار الشريعه وال والقاعده وال
وال داعش هم توانسه يعني شخصيات تونسيه
عندنا مئات المقاتلين التوانسه في صفوف ال
التنظيمات الارهابيه عندنا نساء تونسيات
عندنا اطفال تونسيات موجودين يعني في في
مشكله
كلاح الى الان حتى دول الجوار تر لمساله
الليبيه من مقاربه امنيه
فق لا هذه تداعيات يعني الاخوه في تونس
يخشون من التداعيات الامنيه المفكرين
والسياسيين يتكلمون وهم ليس هناك اي ليبي
قاد اي عمليه ارهابيه في تونس بينما عندنا
هنا في ليبيا غالب العمل يات التفجيرات
الانتحاريه يقوم بها توانس
عندنا كم كبير جدا لم تاتي السلطات التيه
من تونس بشير الج فيما يتعلق ب توقيت هذا
التحرك بالنسبه لدول الجوار من حيث توقيته
الم يكن متاخرا وعن هذه المقاربه الامنيه
كما يراها ضيفي من طرابلس لفهم مشكله
عويصه في
ليبيا ساجيبك حول التاخر في التوقيت لكن
قبل ذلك اسمح لي تفاعل مع السيد صلاح
واعتقد انه باحث
و محايث للواقع في ليبيا اعتقد الحديث عن
فقط توانسه وهذه المسائل يعني لن يتقدم لا
بتونس ولا بليبيا الوضع في تونس وفي ليبيا
معقد ومركب والمساله ليست فقط متعلقه
بقائده مدنيين هو يعلم جيدا نعم ن نعم هو
يعلم جيدا انه نسبه الاجانب الذين يقودون
ميدانيا داعش وغير داعش في ليبيا نسبه
كبيره جدا وليست ليبيين ولا يقتصر الامر
على تونسيين وليس المجال الاني عن
المقاربه الامنيه في فهم عوده لسؤال نعم
عوده عوده لسؤالك حول المقاربه الامنيه
اعتقد انه المتضرر ليس ليبي فقط المتضرر
هو دول الجوار لو نلاحظ الحدود المصريه
والتونسيه والجزائر وما الذي يمر عبرها
دخولا وخروجا الى ليبيا لو نلاحظ السواحل
الليبيه الممتده وا يعني الهجره غير
القانونيه التي تنطلق منها يعني كل هذه
والارقام كثيره والتقارير في هذا ايضا
كثيره كل هذا يجعل من مصلحه الجميع حل هذا
الاشكال من مصلحه الجميع ان يكون هناك حد
ادنى من المسك من الدوله من السلطه في
ليبيا حتى يمكن مواصله يعني العلاقات في
هذا الاطار الاخوي يعني نجاح
كل التوقيت متاخر لان لانه بكل وضوح هناك
يعني عدد من الاطراف راهنت على حسم يكون
عسكري لكن الان يعني ميدانيا لا يمكن
الحديث على اي طرف يعني منتصر عسكريا
وممكن الملاحظه التي يمكن ان يخرج بها
الجميع هو انه حتى من ينتصر عسكريا فهو
منهزم لانه انا للدم الليبي ان يتوقف هذا
الدم الليبي عندما يسيل لا
ياتي صلاح الشلو هل تتوقع ان تفضي هذه
المشاورات الى حلحل للوضع الليبي سياسيا
ومن ثم
امنيا هو بدون شك هناك شروط يعني احن الان
امام الانقسام السياسي الداخلي الليبي
هناك مهمه امام المجلس الرئاسي القائم
اليوم ان هو يحاول ان ينجز شيء وربما هذا
يتيح له فرصه ونافذه لانزاز شيء ليست تطيع
هذا الحوار وهذه التشاو في تونس ان تبني
عليها يعني هذا يعتمد على الليبيين
وقدرتهم على تحسين الحاله في ليبيا قبل ما
يكون نتائج قرارات تشاور بين الاطراف
الاقليميه فالاطراف الان متاحه امامهم
خاصه المجلس الرئاسي الليبي اعتقد ان متاح
امام الان فرصه كبيره جدا لمعالجه الكثير
من الملفات التي ربما تلكا في واذا فعل
هذا فهو سيقود المشهد بدون شك ويدفع الى
الحل بشكل واقعي من طرابلس صلاح الشلوي
محلل سياسي ليبي شكرا جزيلا لك كما اشكر
ضيفي من تونس بشير الجويني باحث في
العلاقات الدوليه ومختص في الشان
الليبي في الملف الثالث والاخير من الحصاد
تتناول سلم الجمل شكل العلاقات المستقبليه
بين روسيا والغرب على ضوء تصريحات لوزير
الخارجيه الروسي بشان حلف شمال الاطلسي
وضروره اقامه نظام عالمي جديد